[Music]
I love you, I love you,
so it's all right. I'm
not going to the meeting. It
's good that Rem is hugging Subaru. It was
hard for 1000 copies.  It's okay if you get hurt like this by yourself, but you don't have to feel so sad anymore
.
Subaru-kun's thoughts will change 6.
[Music] It
's easy to give up. I
'm sorry,
Subaru can't come true. I
'm asking who you were.
When
I was there, I thought you would be kind to the pit,
and when you heard my soft noise, let me squeeze out my whining and squeeze it to the point where I could tear,
so please stand up.
Don't tell me to give up and leave everything to Rem
I love you, I love you, I'm kind to you, love me,
8 more than anyone else in the world  I'll
tackle it, which was also a side music. Bulk I'll show you the weak parts. I'll show you the fragile parts. I'll show you
only the parts that give up.
Listen, it's
totally different.